although there is a large focus on
character storylines
like the shd cleaners and black tusk
just to name a few
there is also a number of smaller
stories in the division which can enable
the player a glimpse into the reality of
what it's really like on the streets of
new york and washington dc
during and after the outbreak a lot of
these i've barely touched on due to a
number of reasons
i may have been busy with the backlog of
larger videos there wasn't quite enough
information
or maybe there were story links that
could have spoiled any kind of
speculation i could have put behind them
it's important to note that some of
these stories go way back to the start
of the division
and you may see me bounce back and forth
between the games
one of these stories was recently
associated with the latest apparel event
phoenix down the story i'm referring to
is about a sale of first wave division
agents with the call sign
noble squad
[Music]
agents when activated are typically
deployed in sales of up to four members
this cell or squad are acquainted with
each other well
they train together and often socialize
in their civilian lives
and they have a strong understanding of
each other's tactical and personal
tendencies
unsurprisingly they all live in a
similar area and close to the region in
which they operate
not only does this mean that they're
already in place to quickly team up
but they also have a very good
understanding of the layout of the land
its people stories utilities and
potential problems
so naturally these cells become like
family to each other
and not only are they responsible for
each other's lives but it also enables
them to confide in each other
seek advice resolve personal conflicts
and possibly most importantly discuss in
a safe environment
the secret lives they're all living
noble squad was a sale of first wave
division agents
cecilia ann tony garcia akil hoopster
and doug sutton as with all of the first
wave agents
their job was to bring order back to the
streets of new york and prevent the
total collapse of society
that was just barely being held together
because of the gangs and rioters rising
up within the city
hey [ __ ] you guys we're just looking out
for ourselves
we're operating under directive 51 and
are fully authorized to put a bullet in
your head if we feel the need
go back to your homes you don't want to
be people we're forced to fire on
oh thank you thank you so much
i thought i was dead
we've got reports of some of those
escaped prisoners from rikers
let's go over there and intercept
i'm gonna go do a little recon down that
way
this was all just part of the territory
for a division agent
cool calm and collected they were able
to defuse the situation
allowing the innocents to get away
unharmed
suddenly they heard over the comms that
a group of escaped felons from rikers
island
were close and actively hostile in the
area
agent sutton quickly set off to scout
ahead of the others to give them an idea
of what they were up against
however it was the rest of noble squad
that would find them first
[ __ ] these guys off oh yeah
oh jesus
i'm getting you out of here oh [ __ ]
let's move
get back here doug we're getting killed
over here
on my way
while sutton was quickly trying to
gather any intel on the rikers island
escapees
the rest of the squad was ambushed and
attacked
pending an alleyway with no chance of
escaping anne garcia
and hoopster did their best in attempt
to hold off the seemingly endless number
of hostiles
from advancing upon them while sutton
tried frantically to make his way back
to his squad
they picked this clean and didn't even
have the decency to put a bullet in my
head
said it was a waste of ammo i'll make
them pay for this
they're all gonna die they're headed
north towards 41st
talking about some kind of safe house
go get them doug
sutton eventually arrived at his squad's
last known location the repair shop at
the end of the alleyway
what he found there completely destroyed
him stripped clean of their equipment
and ammo
their bodies strewn on the ground
decimated and lifeless
he saw that their final moments in life
anne and garcia
in an act of solidarity and love for one
another had held each other's hands
as they took their last breaths
with a sense of dread and despair sutton
made his way further into the store
desperately trying to locate hoopster
towards the back he found him propped up
against a desk
bleeding to death his equipment was gone
the ruckus unmerciful had left him to
die
with his last gasp and ever true soldier
he choked out the direction the convicts
had taken
and then died sutton vowed then and
there
no matter what it took and however long
he would destroy the monsters
responsible for his friend's deaths
it smells like the other i don't know
who those [ __ ] were but they
sure had some bum-ass hardware
[ __ ] yeah look at this piece it is sweet
hey you guys found anything yeah we got
a piece of ass for us to play with
she just walked right in with nap there
playing a place on 41st
yeah all right we're rolling that way
now got ourselves some swag
unbeknownst to them they had a
relentless division agent hot on their
trail
and one of them made the fatal mistake
of being overheard on the phone by their
would-be executioner
sutton now knew where they were heading
he quickly made his way to the location
an apartment building
in the turtle bay district where they
had an unknown female being held captive
although seeing he was heavily
outnumbered sutton had the element of
surprise
and fueled by his rage he burst into the
room
holy [ __ ]
is my mother
sutton exploded into the room with a
vengeance firing everything he had at
his disposal
in the direction of his enemies the
rikers caught by surprise
aimlessly shot at their assailant but
their attempts were futile
and they were quickly taken down most
not even having a chance to move from
where they stood
every single one of them was eliminated
fueled by adrenaline sutton hadley
noticed the bullets that penetrated his
body
and it wasn't until after the fight was
over that he dropped silently to the
ground
by some incredible stroke of luck the
hostage had survived
not a mark on her body using a knife
that had dropped during the altercation
she quickly freed herself and hastily
crawled over to where he lay
thanking the agent for saving her life
but unable to save him in return
she stayed with him as he took his last
breaths and in a final act of kindness
when he died
covered his body
sutton was able to avenge the slaughter
of his squad but ultimately
this came at the loss of his own life
and the civilian he rescued
while she was not originally part of his
plan was saved just in the nick of time
so while this story might be a short one
the tragedies of noble squad
were indirectly responsible for the
rescue of probably the most underrated
character in story
in the divisions franchise april kalahar
as a civilian kalahar would go on to
explore and achieve great feats
between both new york and washington dc
if you are interested in hearing more
about april kelleher i have three cringy
older videos on it
and a couple of more recent ones that
i'll post in the description
if you are at all interested in the
division lore i fully recommend you
check these out
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
you